why do we keep the bacon fat because
it's delicious
hey everyone i'm marisol and today we'll
be making three incredible grazed
chicken dishes we'll start with one base
recipe then we'll do small tweaks
changing out the campbell's broth to
create entirely new dishes let's get
started
so we've preheated the oven to 350 and
i've seasoned these chicken legs with
salt and pepper so i'm going to add a
bit of oil to this pan so my oil is hot
and i'm going to sear this pre-seasoned
chicken skin side down first let's hear
it sizzle
because we have five to six minutes here
we can season the other side of this
chicken a bit more pepper
and a bit more salt
and it's starting to smell so good in
here and it's nice and golden
you can flip it on the other side for
one minute this doesn't need to be
cooked through
our next step is just setting these
aside on the plate so now that we've
seared off our chicken and we have all
these nice tasty bits at the bottom of
our pan we're gonna add some onion and
garlic
i can hear
you so we're gonna cook this off a bit
until it's translucent and fragrant
let's add a nice splash of chardonnay
and we'll reduce the wine tiny bit so
give it a few minutes this is why we're
doing it all in one pan so that there's
more flavor so we've got the flavor of
the chicken we have onion and garlic and
we've added a bit of chardonnay so to
this pan we're gonna add one cup of
campbell's chicken broth with roasted
garlic this is really gonna enhance the
flavors
so i turned up the heat on this and
we're going to add one nice dollop of
pesto
mix it in
and we're going to bring this up to a
gentle boil
so our broth is nice and hot and we'll
return the chicken to the pan
put these chicken legs in skin side
facing up and we're going to top the
chicken with nice vine tomatoes just to
add a tiny bit of acidity
voila and off to the oven we go and
we're gonna leave that in the oven for
about 40 minutes our chicken is cooked
through and we've reduced the sauce a
tiny bit this smells amazing
wasn't this easy we're just gonna change
up the broth and create an entirely new
dish
so i've gone ahead and seared that
chicken we're back to step one now we're
gonna create a whole new dish i'm gonna
start by adding
a bit of garlic and some ginger
some nice flavors going on here so we're
just gonna move this around in the pan a
bit add some carrots add some onion give
it a stir we're just gonna cook that
down for a few minutes and we're gonna
add the broccoli
we gave these veggies a stir and we're
going to add one cup of campbell's thai
chicken broth
for our next step we'll add some coconut
milk
and to really punch up the flavor we're
gonna add a bit of thai curry paste so
we're gonna add these chicken legs and
it's ready to go in the oven and let it
cook for about 40 minutes we reduced the
sauce for about four to five minutes and
you can see that with just a few tweaks
and a new broth we have an entirely new
dish
but guess what
i have another dish for you
[Music]
all right final recipe just like the
other recipes we already seared off our
chicken we'll start by adding to our hot
pan
some bacon
grits sizzle
again we're layering flavors we have the
tasty chicken bits in here
and we're adding the bacon
is there anything better than the smell
of bacon
it's getting
crispy so we're just gonna set this
bacon aside and keep the fat so next
we're gonna add mushroom and garlic and
have that sweat for about four minutes
so i'm gonna add more mushroom
mushroom trio
once we've given this a nice mix we can
add the garlic
and we'll give it a stir again
we're just going to cook down this
mushroom a tiny bit and you see that the
garlic is getting nice and fragrant then
we're going to add the broth i'm gonna
add one cup
of campbell's mushroom broth
this will add richness and a deep umami
flavor let's start with the bacon adding
this back into our dish and adding our
chicken we're just gonna send this in
the oven for about 40 minutes and we're
done
so i reduced the sauce for about four to
five minutes added a splash of cream
and there you go delicious umami flavors
in a rich velvety sauce all right this
is my favorite part the taste test let's
dig in
you can really taste how this chicken
was simmered in this broth
it brings out the spices so nicely all
right what about this guy
this dish is deep earthy and delicious
heading over here
[Music]
it all comes together the tomatoes the
lemon the nice caramelization on the
garlic these were three incredible
dishes
made with really simple ingredients
remember when you changed your broth you
changed a dish thanks for joining me
today and if you try this let me know
how it turns out
[Music]